I have never felt closer to my mom did  the exact same place that she was all  those years ago  only this time we know who the father is  departing yeah typical isn't it wait 20  years for the dead man three coming on  at once you're my mom and I love you so  much  time has been most cruel to you sir your  case age becomes you as it does the tree  a wine and she's I can do this  if I can just be as brave as my mom was  back then I was cheated by unbell I'm  done you know when the world is wide so  I'm gonna make some memories she's  missing her man which one I suddenly  lose we only just met you're not that  kind of girl absolutely not usually  [Music]  she wasn't scared she could do it  because she wasn't alone  you can't tell anybody about the baby  yet I just told bill yeah and I told  Harry I told many many people let's get  the party started grandma you weren't  invited that's the best kind of party  little girl  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you